[Applaus]
[Musik]
für viele ist angela merkel so etwas wie
der könig artus der politik jetzt wo sie
in den ruhestand geht scheinen ihre
partei deutschland ja ganz europa
verweist zu sein wie soll eine zukunft
ohne merkel bloß aussehen viele von euch
können sich vielleicht noch nicht einmal
daran erinnern die europa deutschland
und die cdu vor merkel waren während
ihrer 16 jährigen karriere als deutsche
bundeskanzlerin hat merkel vier
verschiedene us präsidenten gehen und
kommen sehen eine ehre die meisten
autokraten zuteil wird die irland fest
in der hand haben liegt aber die
alleinschuld an dieser kanzler monotonie
wirklich bei angela merkel nicht
wirklich deutschland hat einen spleen
für dauer- kanzler helmut kohl hielt
auch 16 jahre im amt durch und konrad
adenauer immerhin 15 von otto von
bismarck ganz zu schweigen letzterer
musste aber auch keine wahlen gewinnen
nur kriege doch zwischen merkel und
ihrem großen vorgängern gibt es einige
bemerkenswerte unterschiede wie auch
parallelen im gegensatz zu ihrem
stiefvater kohl der vom wähler quasi aus
dem amt gejagt werden musste geht merkel
mit beneidenswerten popularitätswerten
76 prozent der deutschen vertrauen ihr
noch immer mit adenauer verbindet sie
eine hohe zur sabotage parteiinterner
nachfolger so soll der alte nach dem
scheitern ludwig erhards als
bundeskanzler gesagt haben so weide ist
weil ich bemerkenswert ist auch merkels
überragendes image im ausland mit
ausnahme ost und mitteleuropas und
griechenland stellt die überall auf der
welt die am höchsten bewertete
führungspersönlichkeit dar
mit anderen worten du kannst angela
merkel mehr oder weniger mögen aber
eines ist sicher ihr platz in den
geschichtsbüchern was aber wird darin
stehen lasst uns doch hier zu merkel mit
einer anderen könnten regierungschefin
vergleichen die ihr land nachhaltig
geprägt hat denn mit seitlichem abstand
während sich historiker sicher fragen
hatte merkel die größe einer margaret
thatcher gut vielleicht hast du noch nie
darüber nachgedacht aber ich versichere
dir dass wir hier im visual politik team
diese diskussion schon tausendmal
geführt haben
[Musik]
warum nun sowohl merkel als auch sascha
waren die ersten frauen an der spitze
ihrer jeweiligen länder und beide waren
mitglieder von mitte rechts parteien
weiter gewann mehrere wahlen und bald
etablierten sich als
führungspersönlichkeiten von weltformat
doch da hören die gemeinsamkeiten auch
schon auf sascha hatte einfach ein viel
schärferes politisches profil als merkel
und vor allem ist er nicht dass hier
passiert
sozialdemokraten schlagen knapp angela
merkels konservative union bei
historischer wahl in deutschland genau
als margaret thatcher abtrat gewann die
konservativen tories erneut die
parlamentswahl und ihr parteifreund john
major wurde der neue britische
premierminister
dahingegen ist es alles andere als
gelungen einen geeigneten nachfolger
aufzubauen da die bundestagswahl 2021
gewinnen konnte es scheint so als ob die
deutschen zwar nie genug von merkel
selbst bekommen konnten scheinbar aber
die schnauze voll hatten von jener
christdemokratie die merkel hinterlassen
hatte in diesem video hause aus merkels
wichtigste stärken und schwächen an was
ich falsch gemacht hat was ihr
vermächtnis ist und wie sie der welt in
erinnerung bleiben wird heute werden wir
all diese fragen klären aber bevor wir
damit anfangen müssen wir ein wenig geld
verdienen und für euch weiterhin so
tolle videos produzieren zu können hier
kommt also die werbung aber nicht
irgendeine werbung unser sponsor ist
nämlich der anbieter des wirklich guten
pop am dienstag mit wirklich gut meine
ich ein wirklich sicheres vpn eines dass
weder datenverkehr noch meter oder
verbindungsdaten mit lockt und außerdem
jede menge security tools mitbringt
sascha ist aber auch aus vielen anderen
gründen ein tolles vpn natürlich könnt
ihr mit dessen hilfe auf webseiten und
internet dienste zugreifen die in dem
land in dem ihr gerade seid nicht
verfügbar sind ohne zensur und geo
blocking ob daheim oder im urlaub
darüber hinaus bietet es jedoch weitere
sicherheits-features habt ihr nicht zum
beispiel auch ein mulmiges gefühl durch
die allgegenwärtigen werbe popups und
cookies mit zuschlag bekommt er ein
handliches tool namens cleanbag dass sie
alle bloggt und die damit verbundenen
gefahren beseitigt aber nicht nur das
mit nur einem server konto könnt ihr
alle eure geräte vpn registrieren handys
notebooks und sogar europa die smart tvs
denkt wirklich alle arten von geräten ab
ihr bekommt damit einen lückenlosen
schutz so und weil der unsere tollen
fans so lieb haben wir haben hier nur
bereit dieses sponsoring zu übernehmen
wenn euch servtag auch einen
ordentlichen rabatt einräumt und das ist
uns gelungen mit hilfe des rabatt große
politik de bekommt ihr sage und schreibe
83 prozent rabatt und obendrein noch die
ersten drei monate gratis dazu den link
zu diesem angebot findet ihr in der
beschreibung unter diesem video also
nichts wie los besorgt euch sascha und
hält damit gleichzeitig auch unseren
finanzen damit wir für euch weiterhin so
nette videos wie dieses drehen können so
und jetzt zurück zu angela und einem
kurzen blick in ihre vorgeschichte
[Musik]
never touch a running system
um merkels politisches erbe richtig
einordnen zu können müssten wir jenes
ärger verstehen dass sie von ihrem
vorgänger im kanzleramt übernahm die
rede ist vom sozialdemokraten gerhard
schröder
[Musik]
ja genau das ist der typ von gazprom
nord stream und rosneft davor hat er
auch mal kurz für deutschland gearbeitet
genauer gesagt als bundeskanzler kurz im
vergleich zu kohl und merkel aber seien
wir ehrlich auch wenn schröder derzeit
putins man in europa ist seinen job als
künstler hat er ganz gut gemacht
[Musik]
einer seiner größten erfolge war die
agenda 2010 eine arbeitsmarktreform die
deutschland aus der damaligen
wirtschaftskrise führen sollte die späte
ära kohl ende der 90er jahre war durch
extremen reformstau gekennzeichnet die
konservativ-liberale bundestagsmehrheit
und der mehrheitlich rot grün dominierte
bundesrat blockierten sich damals
gegenseitig nichts ging voran alle wagen
gefrustet und hat um kohle und die cdu
so satt das 1998 das erste mal in der
geschichte die mehrheit der wähler den
linken parteien der spd und den grünen
ihre stimme gab nach seinem wahlsieg
übernahm schröder jedoch ein
heruntergewirtschafteten land in die
auslandspresse den titel kranker mann
europas verliehen hatte die
arbeitslosigkeit lag bei über 8% und
schröder wusste dass er deutschland nur
mit liberalisierung flexibilisierung und
harten arbeitsmarktreformen retten
konnte aber diese musste er gegen den
linken flügel seiner partei und die
gewerkschaften durch braucht es ist die
mit kinder manchmal müssen sich eltern
geben und blieb machen um sie ordentlich
zu erziehen schröder entschied sich für
das ganzheitliche und gegen den
populismus für deutschlands aufschwung
opferte er seine eigene macht denn 2005
stürzte in der linke parteiflügel seiner
eigenen partei und es kam zonen
neuwahlen und diese spülten wen an die
macht genau die protagonistin unseres
videos merkel die erste deutsche
bundeskanzlerin
und was passierte als merkel an die
macht kam nun das riesige pakete
arbeitsmarktreformen welche die
regierung schröder verabschiedet hatte
begann zu wirken was soll aus mir nicht
dann schau dir mal diese grafik an
[Musik]
wie du sehen kannst erreichte die
arbeitslosigkeit im ersten jahr nach der
verabschiedung der agenda 2010 ihren
höhepunkt denn solche langfristigen
reformen wirken nicht sofort mit anderen
worten schröder hatte jenes feld
bestellt dessen ernte dann merkel über
viele jahre einfahren konnte sie
übernahm ein gut bestelltes haus so und
jetzt machst du dich sicher was sie
damit so angestellt hat nun in den
ersten jahren ihrer kanzlerschaft gegen
merkel durchaus gut damit um sie
bewahrte eben als politikerin einer
konservativen partei was ihr vorgänger
aufgebaut hatte und zwar auch durchaus
kluge weise sie steuerte deutschland mit
ruhiger aber bestimmte hand durch die
wirtschaftskrise 2008 vollkommen richtig
hatten sie und ihr spd finanzminister
peer steinbrück erkannt dass deutschland
mit seiner durch die schwedischen
reformen erhöhten wettbewerbsfähigkeit
und der stark diversifizierten
mittelständisch geprägten wirtschaft
strukturell bereits gut auf die krise
vorbereitet war und daher vor allem
psychologische maßnahmen brauchte
massnahmen welche er die erwartungen der
menschen beeinflussen sollten und
weniger auf massive staatsausgaben
abzielten sieht hat das richtige verfiel
nicht in panik und tastet das was
bereits funktionierte nicht an
[Musik]
damit verdiente sie sich einen hof
besonnen mit ruhiger hand zu agieren und
die dinge vom ende her zu denken das
problem war nur dieser ruf stier mit der
zeit zu kopf sie fingen an sich auf den
auszügen und ihn schließlich zu
missbrauchen um damit entscheidungen zu
verkaufen die genau entgegengesetzten
charakters waren der erste sündenfall
ereignete sich bei der energiepolitik
seit den 80er jahren hat deutschland
eine starke anti atomkraft bewegung und
tatsächlich wollte schon schröder als
guter linker seinen grünen
koalitionspartner oder vielleicht auch
sandoz von putin einen großen gefallen
tun und beschloss den atomausstieg tja
und was hielt merkel als gute rechte
davon nun schau dir an was die 2009 dazu
gesagt hat merkel verteidigt kernenergie
die deutsche bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel setzt sich dafür ein den
beschluss zum ausstieg aus der
kernenergie bis 2021 rückgängig zu
machen als ihrer mitte rechts koalition
die wahl gewinnt financial times 22 09
2009 und sie gewann diese wahl auch
zusammen mit den liberalen aber die
jahrzehntelange agitation gegen die
kernkraft von zwei jahre später in
reaktorunfall von fukushima ihre
perfekte welle
und ich weiß was viele von euch denken
wie kann ein tsunami vor japans küste
ist nach deutschland stoppen nun er
schreibt er eigentlich nur in die
deutschen meinungsumfragen aber das
reicht schon aus um märkte zum kippen zu
bringen
hunderttausende protestieren in ganz
deutschland gegen atomenergie deutsche
welle 26 2 dritter 2004 liebe freunde
und so wurde aus merkel der
verteidigerin der kernkraft die größte
befürworterin des atomausstiegs heute
hat deutschland fast alle seine
reaktoren abgeschaltet in diesem fall
geht es um eine politik die sich zwar
einen breiten teilen der bevölkerung
großer popularität erfreut jedoch
wirtschafts sicherheits und geopolitisch
katastrophale folgen für deutschland
haben sollte
[Musik]
einerseits musste deutschland durch den
ausstieg aus der atomkraft mehr kohle
verbrennen und dadurch co2 emittieren
und zweitens wurde es noch mehr vom
russischen erdgas abhängig all dies
haben wir in anderen visual politik
videos ausführlich besprochen im großen
und ganzen könnte man mit deutsche
energiepolitik seitdem als
unverantwortlich populistisch und
hysterie getrieben bezeichnen im
gegensatz zur finanzkrise hat sich
merkel von diesem moment an er von
meinungsumfragen als von daten leiten
lassen aber zum glück für sie wird die
folgen ihrer energiepolitik nicht mehr
sie selbst sondern ihre nachfolge
auslöffeln müssen und natürlich die
deutsche bevölkerung
deutsche haushalte müssen mit einem
anstieg der gasrechnungen um 11,5
prozent rechnen heute 2019 2021 das
jedoch ist ein thema für ein ganz
anderes video konzentrieren der uss aber
auf einen anderen wichtigen aspekt
merkels beträchtliche rolle in der
internationalen politik
die kunst der verhandlung
merkel richtig verstehen zu können
müssen erst mal ein sehr wichtiges
konzept begreifen politisches kapital
politisches kapital ist die
glaubwürdigkeit die eine
führungspersönlichkeit in den augen
ihrer wähler oder andere entscheider
besitzt diese glaubwürdigkeit kann
investiert werden um mehr oder weniger
riskante entscheidungen zu treffen oder
um andere politiker auf seine seite zu
ziehen was angela merkel angeht so kann
man feststellen dass die deutschen ihr
quasi unbegrenzt politisches kapital zur
verfügung gestellt haben und die gehen
sie damit um da hätten wir zum beispiel
den fall der euro-krise 2011 erinnerst
du dich noch daran dass deutschland
eines der länder war die am besten aus
der finanzkrise heraus kam zum vergleich
als spanien eine arbeitslosenquote von
über 26 prozent hatte lag deutschland
bei 2,4 prozent
[Musik]
in jenen jahren wurden die länder
südeuropas als pigs bekannt portugal
italien griechenland und spanien diese
vier länder mussten sich geld leihen um
zu überleben aber die märkte verlangten
sehr hohe zinssätze weil sie nicht
darauf vertrauten dass sie ihre kredite
irgendwann zurück bekommen würden so
hatten die pigs nur eine alternative die
europäische union um hilfe zu bitten und
welche ist die größte volkswirtschaft in
europa der ist damals auch noch am
besten ging genau deutschland und wer
war zu dieser zeit bundeskanzlerin dort
genau und so wurde die legende von
angela merkel der austerität zucht
meisterin geboren ok du fragst dich was
austerität bedeutet und im grunde war
merkel bereit den ländern südeuropas
geld zu niedrigen zinsen zu leihen sie
verlangt jedoch dass sich diese länder
nicht nur verpflichten das geld
irgendwann zurückzahlen sondern auch
ihre überzogenen ausgaben kürzen
[Musik]
niedrige vorstellen kannst waren diese
maßnahmen bei den text sehr unpopulär
schließlich will ja kein politiker
beamte entlassen müssen und so fand sich
angela über nacht in hunderten von
karikaturen als strenge deutsche wieder
welche die armen spanier und griechen
zwingen will den gürtel enger zu
schnallen und du wirst dich fragen hatte
sie damit erfolg haben die pigs merkels
austeritätspolitik wirklich umgesetzt
nun auf dem papier ja die realität
jedoch war sagen wir mal etwas komplexer
ein beispiel spanien hat sich
verpflichtet kürzungen vorzunehmen
während es sachen wie diese tat madrid
2020 präsentiert seine olympia bewerbung
in der schweiz ja da hast du richtig
verhört werden spanien auf der einen
seite versprach kein geld mehr aus dem
fenster zu werfen schmiedete madrid
weiterhin munter an seinen plänen für
die ausrichtung der olympischen spiele
und diese sind wie jeder weiß kein
billiger spaß es sollte sich hierbei
übrigens um die olympischen spiele 2020
handeln die selbst japan fast ruiniert
hätten aber diese debatte werden wir
euch in einem anderen video vorstellen
also nicht vergessen was war also unterm
strich das ergebnis vor merkels
autorität politik nun einige länder wie
zum beispiel portugal sind merkels
rezept gefolgt aber die großen länder
spanien und italien haben sich alles
andere eisen austerität verschrieben am
ende kam es doch zum befürchteten
bedingungslosen kapitaltransfer aus dem
reichen europa hauptsächlich deutschland
in die pigs staaten
[Musik]
über welches ausmaß reden wir hier nun
allein die ausweitung von bundesbank
krediten an andere notenbanken und hoch
verschuldete staaten belief sich auf
mehr als eine billion euro bemerkenswert
ist hierbei auch dass die regierung
merkel die ist ohne parlamentarische
zustimmung oder gar debatte durchzog die
frage lautet also berechtigterweise ist
merkel damals ein guter deal gelungen
oder hätte sie mehr aus dem politischen
kapital machen können dass sie die
deutschen zur verfügung gestellt hatten
nun das überlassen wir der meinung jedes
einzelnen ihr könnt also nachher gerne
ausgiebig kommentieren die wahrheit ist
jedoch dass sich merkel in der
euro-krise erst so richtig warm lief
denn 2015 kam jene krise in der merkels
gesinnungs mit einer hose er ins stadium
erreichen sollte die zahl der
flüchtlinge die in europa asyl suchen
steigt 2015 auf den rekordwert von 1,3
millionen research weiter achter 2016
und so begann eine der intensivsten
debatten der eu können wir so viele
menschen aufnehmen die ohne arbeit und
bildung aber mit einer völlig anderen
kultur zu uns kommen merkel die nur
wenige jahre zuvor der ansicht war dass
das maß des zumutbaren bei der
zuwanderung überschritten sei vollzog
die schon bei der kernenergie eine 180
grad wende angela merkel verteidigt die
aufnahme von zehntausenden flüchtlingen
durch deutschland merkels wo mit ihrer
rhetorik die sich über soziale netzwerke
von marokko bis afghanistan wie ein
lauffeuer verbreitete noch viele weitere
integrationswillige nach europa und am
ende dieser planlosen politik war sie
wieder nur eine getriebene getrieben
durch die erst vor schlechten
meinungsumfragen und hässlichen bildern
an den grenzen mit ihrem nationalen
alleingang der unkontrollierten
grenzöffnung im schengen raum steht die
zahlreiche europäische partner dauerhaft
vor den kopf in erster linie den mittel
und osteuropäischen eu mitglieder für
die eine derartige migrationspolitik
inakzeptabel ist ein jahr darauf
entschied sich dann auch noch die
mehrheit der dritten unter dem eindruck
dieser ganzen saison tanzen in eu club
zu verlassen was meint ihr was ist die
bilanz der merklichen europapolitik ist
es nur ein zufall dass in jena in der
angela merkel die mächtigste frau
europas war das einst hoffnungsvolle
friedensprojekt der europäischen
vereinigung in ein unvorstellbar staaten
auflösungsprozess hineingeschlittert ist
doch auch innerhalb deutschlands und
ihrer eigenen partei stieß merkels
migrations wende auf unverständnis
überlegt weil wir reden hier von fast
zwei millionen menschen die als
asylsuchende nach deutschland kam
ernährt werden müssen ein zuhause
brauchen denen die sprache und eine
wenigstens grundlegende arbeits
qualifikation vermittelt werden müssen
damit sie sich integrieren können
experten schätzen die finanzielle
belastung deutschlands allein aus der
migrationswelle 2015 auf rund eine
billion euro ja wieder so eine märkte
billion und ihr wisst dass wir hier bei
der politik schon immer für einwanderung
eingetreten sind ob aus humanitären oder
wirtschaftlichen gründen für
flüchtlingshilfe da wo sie am meisten
sinn macht und für gesunde einwanderung
ohne die deutschland ja ganz europa
demografisch zugrunde gehen würden
[Musik]
dinge lassen sich hier jedoch nicht mehr
schönreden die flüchtlingskrise war eine
komplexe angelegenheit aber man hätte
hier so vieles besser machen können
sowohl aus humanitärer als auch aus
wirtschaftlicher gesellschaftlicher und
außenpolitischer sicht dass wir dafür
schon wieder ein separates video
bräuchten allein aufgrund des ausmaßes
der rasanz und chaotische organisation
dieser zuwanderungswelle war es klar
dass viele menschen dagegen seien würden
vielleicht gelang ihnen ja noch merkels
eigene worte in den ohren das maß des
zumutbaren sei überschritten merkel
reagierte auf diese kritik nun jedoch
mit einer weiteren polarisierung des
gesellschaftlichen diskurses sie ging
davon aus wenn ich meine meinung ändern
müssen dass auch alle anderen auf biegen
und brechen jeder dagegen ihre neue
haltung war wurde in die rechte ecke
geschoben wobei in deutschland die
bedeutung des wortes rechts einfach in
rechtsextremen definiert wurde
[Musik]
in george orwells selbst durch und durch
demokratische linke würde da aus dem
staunen nicht mehr herauskommen die
jahrzehntelange heilige partei person
der union sich so um erst konservative
wähler zu kümmern dass rechts von ihr
keine weitere partei erstatten kann
hatte merkel sowieso über bord geworfen
um die partei rigoros nach links zu
verschieben
in der opportunistischen hoffnung dort
der spd und den grünen mehr reger
abluchsen zu können als sie rechts
verlieren würde damit schuf sie jedoch
nicht nur am rechten rand viel platz für
ein afd die immer mehr durch
tatsächliche rechtsextremen unterwandert
wurde nein merkel besiegelte damit auch
das schicksal ihrer profi losgeworden
und partei so wie eigentlich auch der
bürgerlichen politik in deutschland
insgesamt
denn obwohl heute eine bürgerlich
liberale regierung sogar die mehrheit
der wähler repräsentieren würde stellt
dies nun eine sache der unmöglichkeit da
die zusammenarbeit mit der afg
ausgeschlossen ist eine solche
dauerhafte des balance zwischen links
und rechts kann im sinne eines echten
demokraten sein egal ob man sich als
linker rechter oder liberaler demokrat
sieht die frage ist daher wie konnte das
passieren
ist merkel bei alldem wirklich ihren
prinzipien gefolgt nun genau das werden
wir gleich herausfinden
[Musik]
warum merkel nicht welcher ist
ich weiß was viele von euch denken wir
reden jetzt schon seit einigen minuten
über merkel und wir haben immer noch
nicht über das corona virus gesprochen
im vergleich zu vielen ländern kam
deutschland was die korona infektionen
und todesfälle angeht gut durch die
epidemie und viele beobachter im ausland
schreiben dies merkte zu aber es gab
andere länder die taiwan oder südkorea
die ist viel besser gemacht haben und
vor allem mit geringeren
kollateralschäden märkte zeigte jedoch
wenigstens ein gewisses maß an
ehrlichkeit und zögerte nicht die
schlechten nachrichten selbst zu
überbringen sie hatte keine angst die
deutschen schon am anfang damit zu
schocken 60 bis 70 prozent von ihnen
würden sich mit dem virus infizieren und
dann auch im januar 2021 zuzugeben uns
ist das ding entglitten irgendwie kam
sie da doch wieder zum vorschein leere
direkte unverblümte persönlichkeit die
anleitung so bemerkenswert und
unnachahmlich ist aber die eigentliche
frage die geschichtsbuch frage die wir
uns schon zu anfang des videos gestellt
haben was war merkte es großes
politisches projekt
lasst uns jetzt doch noch mal mit
margaret thatcher vergleichen der erste
große unterschied ist dass margaret
thatcher nie in einer koalition regieren
musste in den elf jahren ihrer amtszeit
hatte zetsche freie hand selbst zu
entscheiden möchte hingegen konnte nie
allein regieren mit anderen worten ihre
partei musste viele zugeständnisse
eingehen aber machte dass merkel
überhaupt was aus was sind ihre eigenen
prinzipien ich meine wir können eine
menge dinge an features erbe kritisieren
aber wir alle wissen was ihr profil und
ihre prinzipien waren und sie hat diese
bis zum ende verteidigt
der politikstil der eisernen lady
erhielt sogar einen eigenen namen denen
der tourismus freund wie feind wussten
womit sie es zu tun haben die
orientierung im fall von märkten ist es
jedoch fast unmöglich zu verstehen was
nun eigentlich ihr politisches projekt
war einen griffigen merkel ismus zu
identifizieren ist quasi ein ding der
unmöglichkeit
oder ist ihr prinzip etwa einfach die
unvorhergesehene wende 2015 sagte sie
versagt europa in der flüchtlingsfrage
dann ist es nicht dass europa das wir
uns vorstellen angela merkel 31 august
2015 aber nur fünf jahre zuvor hatte sie
eine diametral entgegengesetzte haltung
angela merkel der deutsche ansatz für
multikulti ist absolut gescheitert
the guardian 17 prozent 2010 und ich
weiß dass viele von euch sagen werden
lernfähigkeit ist auch nichts schlechtes
und das ist war die frage ist ob es sich
aber um einen echten ehrlichen
meinungswandel handelt oder nur um den
versuch bestimmte wählergruppen zu
gefallen und zwar genau jenen die man
gerade im augenblick im nächsten
machtpolitischen wahlarithmetik benötigt
dieses muster wenn wir auch in merkels
energiepolitik sie war ihrer erster wahl
antrag sprach sich die partei für den
erhalt der atomkraft aus es brauchte
aber nur ein paar demonstration und
meinungsumfragen und möchte kündigte von
einem tag auf den anderen die schließung
aller reaktoren an
[Musik]
und damit er uns klar verstehen aber
handelt es sich nicht um eine
kleinigkeit ohne kernenergie ist
deutschland noch stärker auf erdgas
angewiesen und wie du weißt kommt ein
entscheidender teil davon aus russland
so was nennt man klumpenrisiko ein
geopolitisches dazu außerdem erinnerst
du dich noch an gazprom schulde wir
haben schon zu anfang gesagt dass man
merkel nicht verstehen kann ohne
schröder zu verstehen und die wahrheit
ist dass sich die karrieren dieser
beiden politiker immer wieder
überschnitten haben ja zeitweise hand in
hand gehen und gerade jetzt im jahr 2021
treffen die interessen von schröder der
für gazprom arbeitet und niefern merkel
wieder auf magische weise zusammen
[Musik]
gazprom gibt bekannt dass eine nord
stream pipeline nach deutschland
fertiggestellt ist der atomausstieg die
gleichzeitige abschaltung der
kohlekraftwerke und die massive
förderung von elektroautos haben in
verbindung mit nord 2 deutschland und
ganz europa noch abhängiger von russland
gemacht und das alles wegen einer
energiepolitik die sich auf keinerlei
wissenschaftliche daten stützt nur auf
machtpolitische arithmetik und ein über
jahre hinweg einseitig beeinflusst
öffentlichen meinung die ihnen viel
aufständen ländern der welt nur
belächelt wird mit anderen worten wir
können nicht leugnen dass merkel ein
gewisses charisma und eine
anpassungsfähigkeit an ereignisse an den
tag gelegt hat die durchaus
bewundernswert sind aber gelang es ihnen
all den jahren wirklich eine klares
politisches projekt erfolgreich
umzusetzen sowie adenauer den
wiederaufbau er hat das
wirtschaftswunder brandt und schmidt die
mit dem friedensnobelpreis
ausgezeichnete ost und west aussöhnung
polen die wiedervereinigung und schröder
das zweite wirtschaftswunder
nachkriegsdeutschlands wofür aber stand
merkel sicherlich nicht für die
modernisierung der infrastruktur und des
imf us zeitalter steckengebliebenen
staatsapparats so wie am ende der ära
kohl hinterlässt merkel einen nicht
unerheblichen modernisierungsstau sonst
nun fasste sie oft durchaus die
richtigen themen an aber was kann
unterstrich dabei heraus
[Musik]
europäische integration und solidarität
könnten ein entscheidender trumpf im
weltweiten web brender großmächte seien
aber unter merkel wurde die eu nur
gespalten und hat sogar großbritannien
verloren vitale einwanderungspolitik
wäre für deutschlands zukunftsfähigkeit
einer über lebenswichtige aufgabe aber
hat merkel mit ihren entscheidungen
einer nachhaltigen integration und
entwicklung der gesellschaft wirklich
genutzt oder eher geschadet der kampf
gegen jede form von extremismus ist
elementar aber ist es wirklich hilfreich
jeden als rechtsextremisten zu labeln
der den aktuellen regierungskurs
kritisiert
[Musik]
der klimawandel ist ein sehr bedeutendes
globales thema aber waren ihre
überstürzten energiepolitischen
entscheidungen auch hier das richtige
ihr seht wir haben viel zu diskutieren
also was meint ihr was ist merkels erde
hat sie wie schröder ein gut bestelltes
haus hinterlassen
durch was wird sie der nachwelt in
erinnerung bleiben und welche lektionen
sollten politiker die noch aktiv sind
von ihr lernen wir immer sind wir auf
all eure meinung zu diesem thema
hochgradig gespannt ich hoffe also dass
euch dieses video gefällt hat fast jedes
detail des netzwerks freuten und
vergesst nicht das abo mit glöckchen um
keines unserer videos mehr zu verpassen
macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]